president biden was one of many
democrats who said cuomo should resign
and was asked about that yesterday
how would you assess
his 10 and a half years
as governor of the state
in terms of his personal behavior or
what he's done as a governor but he's
done a hell of a job
but he's done a hell of a job
and uh
i mean both on everything from
access to voting to infrastructure the
whole range of things
that's why it's so sad
cbs news senior white house and
political correspondent ed o'keefe asked
that question and he joins us now ed
good morning good to see you uh so
governor cuomo continued to deny
wrongdoing even as he announced his
resignation so why step down now
because while he continues to have this
legal fight ahead of him vlad this
political fight was just unwinnable for
him we had learned in the last 48 hours
or so that while a majority of the
assembly was ready to move with
impeachment virtually all of the new
york state senate democrats and
republicans was likely going to vote for
his removal whether that happened in a
few weeks or a few months or if the vote
had been taken this week he knew that
and he knew as he said in his statement
as he announced his resignation that it
was something that would just be dragged
out for too long and turned out to be
too expensive for the state but also by
removing himself now from the political
fray at least he may be thinking that it
reserves his ability to get back into it
one day if he's somehow able to get out
from under this legal fight you know you
and i talked about this yesterday on
cbsn our 24-hour digital network what
happens next he's got two weeks before
he effectively leaves office that's
right he's got a transition obviously
now between
when he leaves and and he has to prepare
for a legal fight if anything he's
probably going to face civil suits uh
and there are a handful of district
attorneys in the state who are reviewing
the attorney general's work and trying
to sort out whether or not there's going
to be a criminal case so uh you know
watch what he does in the next two weeks
in terms of getting ready for his
successor does he do anything to help
her uh and i know a lot of people in
albany will be watching to see whether
he's got some other plan uh either to
help himself or or to do something
in this two-week period
all right he will be replaced by
lieutenant governor kathy hokel it's
history in the making she becomes the
first woman first female governor of the
state of new york what do we know about
her and not only the first woman but for
someone who's an upstate new york native
i can tell you people all across the
state intrigued by the fact that she'll
be the first governor not from new york
city in about a hundred years she's from
buffalo erie county uh and as you said
the first woman someone who has traveled
the state and keeps a pretty aggressive
travel schedule all 62 counties every
year knows a lot of the democratic party
insiders and players but has never been
in a position to really run something
this large and this important the state
so she's going to need a lot of help
from legislators who are ready to
support her and we're told that
president biden will probably speak with
her in the coming days to try to offer
his support but certainly history in the
making and she's going to have to think
immediately about next year when she if
she wants to could be on the ballot to
seek a full term ed quickly before we
let you go when you look at the at the
governor's legacy now and it is tied to
this it is also the things that he did
how will people remember his time in
office well i mean there were a lot of
things he did obviously the pandemic you
talked to people in albany or across the
state they say he did a masterful job of
keeping the state safe and dealing with
the situation and serving as a tonic to
many people
compared to the federal response
especially in those early weeks and
months and they credit him with you know
a lot of major infrastructure projects
across the state they're rebuilding
laguardia airport they've rebuilt other
parts of the state as well he tried to
buck up the economy but you take his
behavior in this situation his alleged
behavior plus a host of scandals over
the last several years and they said it
was time to hold them accountable all
right ed thank you very much